And when, you know, it's
a performance-based industry.
So when we perform, we're hyped. Like, it's
a lot more than just that play, right there.
There's a lot that goes into it.
And I don't think
a lotta people can relate.
That's why they're so quick to penalize
or make it a bad thing
when it's, like, really like,
I'm showing you that I really care
about what I do.
- I have a crazy story
about, not necessarily this studio,
but just, like, right underneath us
in this parking lot.
- Mmhmm. Tell me!
- So last time I parked in this parking lot,
there's a guy who's, like, pretty
much like one of my OGs out here now.
His name's Paul. Shout-out to Paul.
He lived in the underground tunnels,
like, homeless
underneath Vegas for, I think he said
three years.
And he goes down there
now. He has a foundation called Shine a Light.
And he goes and gets people out.
And I went down with him one weekend,
and we parked in this parking lot and went,
like, underneath the bridge right here.
And we're underneath the sewer
tunnels, walking around,
giving supplies to, like, homeless people
that live down there.
So I'm like—when you sent me this, I was like,
"This seems really weird."
- "I've been here."
Yeah. OK, first thing, that's amazing.
But I have a bunch of questions.
- All right.
- First off, did not know
there were underground tunnels in Vegas
where a lot of homeless people live.
- Yep.
- Did you know that before you came here?
- No, I did not.
- OK, so talk to me about that.
- I mean, like everybody else, I thought
only the Strip existed in Vegas.
- Yeah.
- So, meeting this guy Paul, he's
been really helpful as far as, like,
my recovery journey.
- Yeah.
- And I went down there with him,
and there's, like, 1,500
people living down there.
And we brought them supplies like batteries
and socks and snacks and water
and stuff like that.
- That's amazing.
- And there's people down there living.
And we came across this one guy, they
were trying to get him to come out.
But he was like, "Nah, I'm comfortable."
Like, "I'm not leaving here."
So he was just, like, comfortable
living down there.
And they have just their own ways,
and they don't have to interact
with people. You know, they probably been hurt
in some way by the world
that they wanna live in that place,
and they feel like
that's a good place for them, so—
- Yeah.
- It was an incredible—just from my perspective.
- Yeah. That's so interesting
to think, like, their comfort is coming from
this thing that we probably, like,
can't even fathom.
They're like, "Well, this is kind of
my reality now, and I'm OK in this moment."
So, Darren Waller, NFL
tight end, goes down in these tunnels.
Were there any reactions from people like,
"Is that him?" Or were
most people unaware?
- Nah, they didn't really know, cuz
you know, they were just kinda like,
"What y'all doin'? What y'all want?"
- Yeah.
so it's a, it's a crazy environment
down there.
- Yeah.
It's like its own community.
- Right.
- Oh, my gosh. Well, that's amazing
you went down there and helped.
Have you only gone once?
Are you gonna go more?
- I've only been once.
- OK.
- Probably when the
offseason comes around
I'll go down there again,
you know?
- Yeah.
- It's, it's just incredible.
I wanna, probably wanna bring some of my
teammates or somebody with me, you know? It's dope.
- I love that. OK,
so I have one more question about it
cuz this is so interesting to me.
So this guy you're saying is your OG,
how did you meet him?
- So I got connected with him through—
there's a Ford dealership
that I have a partnership with out here.
- Yeah.
- And they do a lot of charity work, and
they work with this guy and his foundation.
So I met Paul, and then I was like,
"Paul's, like, a real dude."
And he invited me to, like, some meetings
out here and just hanging around,
you know, like-minded people.
- Yeah.
- And he's really been, become somebody that
I lean on.
- Yeah.
Oh, my gosh. I love this.
You have just become,
I feel like, such an important figure
in this community for Vegas.
Every time I've told somebody I'm coming
to your interview, they get incredibly excited.
There's so much to dive into.
I wanna talk about all the stuff
you've done with the community,
your journey and all these things.
But, you know, there's something
I have to get out of the way.
- All right.
- Because everybody said, "This needs to be
the first thing you ask him about."
- Oh, boy.
- This taunting call. [Laughing]
- How do we feel about this taunting rule,
and will you ever spike a football again?
- The taunting rule,
I feel like, is a little over the top, you know?
- Yeah.
- I get why they may have thrown
a flag on mine because mine was, like,
on the opponent's sideline.
So the ref, like, usually
it's like, if you go on the sideline
and you do something,
like, they're instantly gonna throw it.
- Yeah.
- So I was just, you know, hyped
because we had been struggling to that point.
That was our first first down of the game,
and it was almost halftime.
So I was just like, "Let's go." Like,
I was just, like, getting some frustration out.
And they threw that.
And I was just like, "Man, that's nuts."
And then I spiked one, like, later
in the game. Like, it wasn't as egregious,
and it was, like, in the middle of the field.
And they came up to me, and
they were like, "Whoa, you gotta
chill out. You gotta chill out." I'm like, nah.
- What?!
"I can't be passionate
and have fun and be exciting?"
That's my issue with the taunting rule is
I feel like fans
like seeing their favorite players
get into it in that way—
- Right.
- And, like, feel aggressive and be pumped
when you do something that's like a big,
you know, momentum swing in the game.
Like, do you almost feel like you're
having to hold back your emotions a lot
cuz that flag is gonna come?
- I mean, I don't think I'm really gonna
focus too much on that.
- Yeah.
- Maybe, like, not throw the ball crazy
all over the place.
But I can still, like,
just, like, drop the ball lightly
and still get up and kinda
go crazy
cuz I don't feel like a lot of people
can relate to that level of emotion
cuz we put so much into the game
on a daily basis.
And when, you know, it's
a performance-based industry.
So when we perform, we're hyped. Like, it's
a lot more than just that play, right there.
There's a lot that goes into it.
And I don't think
a lotta people can relate.
That's why they're so quick to penalize
or make it a bad thing
when it's, like, really like,
I'm showing you that I really care
about what I do.
- Yeah. Like, I'm trying to win this.
- Yeah.
- No, I love it. OK,
tell me, what was your
"welcome to the NFL" moment
where you were like,
"All right, this is different. Like,
these are the big boys"?
- It was my rookie year in Baltimore, 2015.
We were playing the Cleveland Browns,
and there was a safety on their team named
Donte Whitner. He played for the 49ers,
was where he was most well-known.
And he caught me over the middle
on a crossing route, hit me here in my chest
and gave me a concussion.
- [Laughing] You're like, "Oh, boy.
Is this gonna be week in, week out?"
- Just off the whiplash and like,
I, like, crawled probably like five yards.
And I was like, "Nah,
I gotta get up." Like, I just ran off the field
and then went straight to the tunnel.
My day was over with, so.
- Yeah, you're like, "Get me in this booth, 'Te.
Like, this is not meant for me."
- Donte Whitner.
- Yeah, I love that.
OK, so, my mom was very excited about me
doing this interview
because you are her fantasy
football tight end.
-  OK.
- Now, are you one of those players,
it's like, "I do not care about fantasy."
Do you like fantasy?
Did you ever play fantasy?
What's your stance on it?
- I think I played fantasy twice in my life.
One time I think I was in middle school.
- Yeah.
- And that was the year Tom Brady
blew his knee out
the first game of the season.
And so I was like,
"Yeah, I'm not doing this."
- Did you have Brady?
- Yeah.
- Oh, yeah.
- [Laughing]
- Then you were done.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Fantasy is, like, 75 percent luck.
It drives me crazy, but
- Right.
- I cannot stop playing it.
- And then I was out of the league
in 2017, and a girl I was
dating at the time, her family needed,
like, one more body for her fantasy league.
- Yeah.
- And I was like, "Sure." I pick my team.
I thought they were good players,
but I think I was, like, second-to-last in the league.
- [Laughing]
- So I really didn't know what I was doing.
- I mean, that's kind of how it goes.
That's kind of how it goes.
OK, so for people
who are very into fantasy,
you are obviously one of the top players.
You get a lot of points.
But tell me, like, five guys
you would be like, "OK, I'm OK being traded
for these guys." Cuz there was a trade
controversy in my league for you.
Someone didn't want to give you up,
but someone really wanted
to give up a lot of pieces to get you. So
I'm just curious as to your stance. Like, who are some guys
you'd be like, "OK,
I understand this trade"?
- I'll probably say just all those
those running backs, you know?
- Yeah.
- Cuz they can rack up so many points
with so many touches, like McCaffrey,
Alvin Kamara, Dalvin Cook…
- Mmhmm.
- Saquon Barkley.
I mean, there's so many that can just
rack it up. Derrick Henry.
- Mmhmm.
- So there's any of those running backs or,
you know, a wide receiver that's just getting
all kind of targets or even, like,
I mean, any quarterback, like a Kyler Murray.
- Totally. All the points.
- He's doing all that crazy stuff, so.
- Yeah.
Well, one thing I really like about tight
ends, you know, in this day,
is you guys really are receivers, right?
Like, you are guaranteed points.
You, Travis Kelce,
George Kittle. Like, it's,
you get a lot of points from tight ends.
How have you seen that position just evolve
throughout your playing career?
- It's just guys that can do everything
that football requires, honestly.
- Mmhmm.
- Because you look at it it's
we gotta block big defensive ends,
Khalil Macks and Chase Youngs,
week in and week out, Myles Garretts.
And then you gotta run routes against
defensive backs that are fast and talented,
and you gotta be, you know, quicker
and stronger than linebackers as well.
So it's like
- Yeah.
- you gotta be able
to do all these skills
that are already so hard in their own right.
And you have to do what offensive linemen
do and do what wide receivers do.
- Mmhmm.
- So they're asking a lot of you.
And we've just kinda added an athletic
speed, explosiveness element to it.
- Mmhmm.
- It's not just, like, a big, stocky,
burly position anymore.
- Yeah. Like, you guys can do anything.
- Right.
- OK, so I'm gonna name some receivers.
You tell me what makes them special,
OK? What makes Travis Kelce special?
- Overall control.
Like, nobody is ever dictating
the game to him.
He's never running, like, 100
miles per hour.
I mean, my coach always told me,
like, you don't have to run every route
in fifth gear,
but he can run those routes in,
like, third or fourth gear, and just be smooth
and just have you falling
all over the place.
- Yeah.
And then turn it on.
- Yes.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Just, his change-of-speed is ridiculous.
- OK, what makes George Kittle special?
- He's just an animal, you know?
Mindset-wise and blocking people.
He just loves dumping
people on their head.
And just, he just plays with,
like, people don't
wanna really get involved with that.
He's so physical, and he'll just drag
five people
- Yeah.
- down the field.
- Easily.
Yeah. OK, what about T.J. Hockenson?
Cuz that's somebody that I think
is really emerging right now.
- I mean, similar to George Kittle, honestly.
They all come from that tight end factory,
you know,
- Mmhmm.
- from Iowa.
So...ability to block and then make
explosive plays in the passing game.
He's faster than you think he is.
- Yeah.
- He can jump higher than you think he can.
And he's just real, real smooth.
I noticed that at the Tight End University,
like, he's, like, I was like,
wow, like, he's real smooth.
- Yeah, he's different. Yeah. OK,
what makes Darren Waller special?
- I'll say just a combination of speed,
route-running, versatility from out wide,
in the slot, hand in the ground,
being able to pass-protect, run-block
in the run game
- Mmhmm.
- in big personnel groups.
So there's nothing on the field
that my team doesn't ask me to do.
So I feel I just have versatility.
- Yeah.
I mean, it's no secret
you are incredibly talented, right?
But if we say that a 10 is, like, peak,
prime Darren Waller, OK?
Like, that's the ceiling is a 10.
Where do you feel like
you are at this moment? What number?
- Wow. Yeah, definitely not a 10.
I'll probably say, like,
maybe like a 7, 7.5.
- OK, so this isn't even full form.
- I feel like there's
still a lot of growing to do.
- Yeah.
What is that growing? What's in that gap?
What will take you from a 7 to a 10?
- You know, being able to take over games
week in and week out.
You know, make those winning plays.
Cuz there was a lot of opportunities
where, you know, we lost games,
like, in the last minutes, in the last seconds.
So it's like, you know, making those plays
from my teams, like,
you know, maybe like a Kobe
Bryant would. Like,
they would always lean on him.
So it's, like, being in that role
where my team could lean on me.
And just, like, just as far
as, like, the run game, blocking-wise,
it's just so, something that's so new and foreign
to just my body type and my skill set.
- Yeah.
- So it's just improving in that
and the little things,
just the things that nobody really notices.
Like, the pass game
I feel like I'm well on my way
and continuing to get better.
But it's just the run game
and those little things.
- How far are you from
10 Darren Waller?
- You just continue
to stack individual days at a time,
- Yeah.
- and you never know when that can happen.
You know, I feel like
there will never be a time
where I'm still playing football
and I can't improve at something.
- Mmhmm.
- So I feel like I may
not even never get there.
But, you know, it is what it is.
- So when it comes to football,
what is driving you on the field?
Like, are you a player that says, "OK,
I want to be the best tight end
in the NFL right now"?
Is that a goal of yours,
or what is the thing
that is pushing you to be better
when it comes to just playing football?
- I wouldn't say my goal is to be
the best tight end in the NFL
cuz I'm just not really
into comparing myself to other people.
- Mmhmm.
- That just doesn't work
well as far as my mental approach.
Because I do that
and I'll start worrying about what
other people are doing and worry
about stats, this and that.
And it's, like, that
just drains my energy kind of.
- Mmhmm.
- And so I just feel like me
giving the best effort I can and being the
most prepared and having my attitude
in a positive manner at all times,
that's what success is to me.
And then all the results
will take care of themselves.
- Mmhmm. So that's your goal every time you step onto the field.
- Yeah.
- And that's how you approach the game.
- Right.
- And you have seen that work for you?
- Yeah, it works for me.
It allows me to, you know, have an impact
on the people that are around me.
- Mmhmm.
- And not just make it all about me
and it's my show or anything like that.
- Yeah.
- It's about, you know, what kind of impact
I can have on the people around me.
I try to be very conscious of that.
- Yeah. I remember
I read this quote, and it said,
"You should always do it out of love
and never for it."
- Yeah.
- Like, that's—
- I shared that exact quote.
- Did you?
- On my Instagram probably a few weeks
ago. So I know exactly what you're talking about.
- Oh, no way.
You are very good quotes
on your Instagram stories.
So if you aren't following
Darren on Instagram,
you absolutely should
cuz there's always a good quote.
You're sharing one, you're posting one.
- I'm sharing it for me, you know? Like...
- Yeah.
- It's something that convicts me first,
and then I feel like it would
convict somebody else.
- Yeah. No, and they definitely do.
There's obviously so many things
that I wanna talk to you about.
You are someone who it is
not an exaggeration to say
is a complete open book,
which I think is important for people
to feel like they really understand
you and see what they see
in themselves and you.
So I just applaud all that you do
in talking about your life
and what you've been through
and where you're going.
I think it's really, really important.
- Thank you.
- But something that really struck me
when I was watching a lot of interviews
prepping for this one.
Obviously, a lot of people are talking
about the same thing, which is your road
to recovery, your addiction.
Is that something
that you enjoy discussing,
or is it a thing that you just continue
to be asked about, if that makes sense?
- There's, I mean, there are some times
where it's, like, I do
feel like it can get repetitive, but
- Mmhmm.
- at the same time, it keeps me in the mode
that I'm in when I'm talking about it.
- Yeah.
- It makes me not, like, you know, forget
what life used to be like.
- Mmhmm.
- And, you know, the kind
of thinking and the habits that I left behind.
Because if I don't,
you know, do the work that's necessary day
in, day out, I could slip back into those.
And I do find myself, I sometimes,
like, my thinking, just kind of slipping
if I'm just doing, doing, doing,
going, going, grinding, grinding
and not focusing on myself like
- Yeah.
- I know that I should on a daily basis.
You know, it can start to weigh on me, so.
- Yeah.
- I just, talking about it keeps me,
yeah, it just keeps me in that mode.
- Mmhmm.
You said that sometimes
you'll find yourself going, going, going
and thinking, OK, maybe you might slip.
Can you tell me more about what
that looks like, what that feels like?
- Yeah, it's just like I'm
so caught up in the performance of my
day-to-day. Like, I'm in a performance
industry, you know, and just,
my brand matters,
my stats matter, all these things matter.
And it's just like...
And I come across all these people,
and it's like they love me for what I do.
But it's, like, when I take a step
back, it's like,
what about, this is going to end someday.
What is it going to be like then? Like,
who am I going to be? Like,
am I going to be somebody that doesn't
know who I am when it's over with?
And so it's, like, I gotta make sure
that, you know, in the mornings
and afternoons, in the evenings, I'm,
you know, just checking in
and just being still and just listening
to what's going on inside me.
- Mmhmm.
- And yeah, it's just
gotta be a good balance.
Like, even this last week,
like, I'm feeling kind of overwhelmed.
I'm, like, I'm going to these events,
and all these people want to take pictures,
and it's just, like,
all right, like, this is cool.
Like, I understand what it means to them.
But it's, like, it's
not like they really try
to get to know me, and so it's like
I'm spending all my time doing this,
and I imagine that amount of time with,
you know, journaling or meditating
or talking to people in my life that
I could really talk about
real-life shit with.
- Yeah.
- I don't know if you can cuss.
- You can cuss. Cuss as much as you want.
- All right.
- Yeah.
So when you were checking in
with yourself, what are the questions
you're asking yourself?
- Like, who are you?
It's just like, to see
if I'm, if you know, my ego
wants to attach to football
or if it wants to attach to music
or if it wants to attach
to any of these other things or instead of, like,
you know, just my values.
Like, making sure that I'm staying on those
and then just listening.
Cuz thoughts are gonna come up.
And then that's where I can kinda sift
through 'em and realize, like, you know,
I don't have to really go with the narrative
that my mind wants to do
because it's always
just chirping and chirping and
chirping and just
trying to beat me up one minute
and then trying to make me think
I'm the greatest thing
in the world the next minute.
So it's just trying to, like, find
that even ground.
- Yeah.
And that's what you're trying
to stay on track with every single day.
- Yeah.
- So when you talk about your journey
and things that have happened to you,
- Yeah.
- So when you talk about your journey
and things that have happened to you,
does it make you sad?
Does it just make you reflective?
Does it make you proud of where
you've come? Like, what emotions come
with discussing it but then also, like,
discussing it all the time?
- There's a lot of times
where I can kind of, like, laugh
looking back in a way,
and people will kind of be, like,
how can you even laugh
about that kind of stuff?
- Yeah.
- But it's like, you know, you
do the work to kind of move on from it
and see it in a different way.
But I do kinda get sad
because there are some times where
I'll still think, like, I don't
deserve good things,
even though I may be in this space.
And there's, like,
a lot of good has happened.
I'm still so accustomed to thinking in
that mode where things weren't going well
- Mmhmm.
- and how, like, just that place of, you know, suffering
and just hopelessness
kinda got comfortable.
Like, I was telling you about the person
that was underground.
- Yeah.
- And it's just you get
kinda stuck in that mode.
And now things are going well.
It's like, there are days
when I can find a way
to just be like,
"How do I just blow this shit up?"
And just like,
- Yeah.
- because some days I just not really be feeling it.
But to bring myself out of it
into the positive, like, that's
what talking about it does for me.
You just put it in the air,
and it's kinda like, all right,
like, it's not as bad as I'm making it
seem, you know? My mind
can make me think I'm alone
sometimes.
- Yeah.
- It's, like, I'm not alone.
Like, people are here for me. They love me.
They support me.
So I gotta just keep talking,
keep that dialogue going.
- Yeah.
So you feel like in
some ways there was, like,
kind of a home in the sorrow?
Like…
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
- It's, like, I just got, like I said,
I got comfortable there,
and there was times where it was like,
yeah, I wanted to change,
and I would say like, "Yeah, I'm
about to stop doing these pills on Friday."
And Friday would come, and I'd be like,
"Mm, nah, I'm going to go through the weekend."
- Mmhmm.
- And it's just like,
you know, you get so comfortable, and it's,
like, I don't, that change seems way
harder than just sitting
right here in it does.
- Mmm. Can you dive into that more?
Cuz I think that's interesting.
- Yeah. I mean, you just get so used to,
you become a victim,
and you start making excuses
and justifying why you do
certain things.
- Yeah.
- Or justifying why you judge people in a certain way.
And it's like, you know,
you get comfortable there.
And then when it's, like,
when it's time for you
to look at your own problems, you know,
clean up your own side of the street,
that's some dirty business.
That's like, that can get pretty
nasty and ugly.
- Yeah.
- And not a lot of people
wanna look in that mirror, you know?
- Mmhmm.
- So it's easier to just
be where you at
and be in the habits that you created.
- So you said that, you know,
sometimes you struggle with, saying,
"OK, do I deserve good things?" Or, like,
"Do I just wanna blow this shit up?"
Can you give me an example of a time
that you have felt that way?
- I mean, keeping it real,
there was, like, a few days ago where I woke
up, and I was like, "Man, like,
I'm here, and, like, I'm here
for a reason. God has me
here playing football for a reason."
But today I'm not feeling this shit, like.
- Yeah.
- Like, fuck this today, like for real.
- Mmhmm.
- And it's like, but that's when I can kind of
sit down and be still and just, you know,
listen to myself and listen to who God is to me.
And that's when I can come
back down and be, like,
all right, like, you know,
you're a little over there.
You can just come back over here to the middle
a little bit and relax, like,
this day is gonna get better.
We haven't even got started yet,
and you all the way down there.
- [Laughing]
- So just come on back here, and...
- Bring it back. Yeah.
- We can figure this thing out.
- So someone is going to hear
that and say, wow,
so a few days ago, an NFL player felt like,
"I just wanna blow this shit up.
This isn't what I wanna do right now."
What is your response, then, in terms of,
right, like, just because I do this
and you see me doing this and
I can catch a football and I can make a
touchdown, do all these big plays,
there are still times where I'm struggling
with so many things
- Yeah.
- that you're
still not seeing?
- Right.
- Cuz you mean,
you're like, a few days ago,
it's like, well dang, a few days ago
there was a game, like, y'all played good,
like, what is it about that that still can
bring you back to certain places?
- I mean, it's just, like, it's challenging.
And, you know, I used to just
run from challenges, whether it was, like,
a tough conversation or, you know,
just having to own up to my stuff
or having to get my act together.
Like, I would always just,
you know, run from it,
whether it be in the forms of drugs and
alcohol or women or anything.
Like, you can run from things
in a lot of different ways.
And so that would just be my habit.
And now it's, like, nah, like, my character
now is to just face those things head-on.
And that can be tough.
It's, like, I'm not waking up everyday, like,
I'm going right towards
my challenges.
- Yeah [Laughing]
- I'm just gonna, you know,
- Let's conquer!
- This is going to be great today.
You know, most of the time it's like, man,
I really gotta have this conversation.
Or I really need to sit here
and reflect on this or really
find something that I can take
and grow forward with.
And so, yeah, it's not always—like,
football is a challenging game,
just putting up with all the marketing
and dealing with all these people.
And it's like, it's a challenging thing
for somebody like me
that wants to isolate as well. So
it's, in a lot of challenging environments
and just telling myself, like,
this challenge is gonna help me grow.
It's not gonna just tear me apart
or anything. Like, it's here
for me to learn lessons,
and I go on to the next one
and just keep going.
- Mmhmm.
I know you were first introduced
when you were 15...
- Yeah.
- years old.
- Can you talk to me about that moment,
what drug it was you tried,
how it happened?
Just tell me the story of that day.
- Yeah, so, leading up to that moment,
you know, I was always like,
you know, trying to be, like,
almost a goody two-shoes kid.
Like, I was like I'm not gonna drink,
not gonna smoke. Like, kind of seeing it
from a place of self-righteousness.
- Mm.
- But then, you know, I guess I was, like, 15,
and I was good at football growing up.
But then people started growing past me,
and I was real small,
- Yeah.
- like my first years of high school,
and so I was riding the bench.
- Yeah.
- And so I kinda put my eggs into the football basket
pretty early on.
And then it was just like, well,
that's not working.
And I wasn't, like, popular
or anything like that.
So I was just kinda, like, lost and feeling,
you know, kinda sad.
And, you know, my friends presented it
in a way that was, like, this will
make you feel good. And I was like,
you know, I'd like to feel good,
so.
- Yeah.
- You know, I'll try it, like, I got nothing
to lose right now.
And so I tried it,
and it was just, like, this works.
Like, it's like, it makes me feel good.
Like, it give me the tingles and all that.
And then it's also, like, my mind's always
revving at a thousand miles per hour.
It slows my mind down.
- Mmhmm.
- And it's like, OK, like,
these people, like,
do the same thing I'm doing.
It allowed me to make friends.
So it was, like, all those things made it, like,
oh, yeah, this is just,
this is what I do now. This is who I am.
- Mmhmm.
- And never even thought
of giving it up for the next
10 years.
- Yeah.
Do people underestimate, like,
how hard it is to fall into drugs?
- Yeah. I mean, it's real easy.
- Or how easy it is to fall into drugs?
- Yeah, I would say, yeah, it's easy.
And, like, looking back, it was like,
people was like, "Weed is a gateway drug." People were
like, "Man, weed ain't no gateway drug."
I was, like, for me,
I mean, I see for a lot of people
how it is, but, like, for me,
like I didn't even start with weed.
So it was just, like,
a whole different experience.
People were like, "Damn, like,
you just started with pills?" And I was just like,
I mean, yeah, I didn't, this is just where
I ended up.
- Yeah.
And so what specifically, you said
you started with pills? What...
- It was, like, Percocets.
The, you know, pain pills
you get from a surgery, Oxycodone,
hydros, stuff like that.
- Yeah.
Started drinking after that, and
then I started smoking weed. Then Xanax,
Adderall, cocaine, molly.
Probably like that. Never did,
I always say, like, I never got into heroin,
but I was, like, I mean, Percocets
are basically heroin in a different form,
like.
- Mmhmm.
- So I'm not better than nobody else cuz
I didn't
- Yeah.
- try heroin, you know, so it was just damn near everything.
- One moment you talk about was when you
were in your car and you overdosed.
- Yeah.
I believe that was what, 2017?
- Oh, yeah, yup. August 11, 2017.
- Yeah. August 11, 2017.
In that moment when you overdosed,
did you think, like, that was it?
Like, was that your thought?
- I did not think it was it,
but I was like, I'm about to, like,
pass out or something, like.
- Yeah.
- Cuz I was, like I said,
I was at the grocery store parking lot,
and I was going to, like, get some beer or something,
and I was getting outta the
car, and it was just like,
nah, I can't get out of the car.
I feel like I'm just...fall out on the ground,
and it's, like, midday.
So I was like, nah,
let me just sit in the car and just chill.
- Mmhmm.
- And, uh...
And I was high as shit. Like, I
didn't have the car on.
Like, I was just sitting there.
- Yeah.
And just...it was like somebody pulled the TV out
from, the cord from behind the TV
and just the TV just [powering down sound effect].
And it was just like, just went black.
I feel like I woke up like a second later,
and it was, like, nighttime.
And I was, like, the sweatiest
I've ever been in my life.
- Mmhmm.
- And it was cold and, like,
just like off, and
it was, like...I was, like, scared. It
scared me enough, I was like, yeah, like this
the first time I feel like
I'm not in control.
Like, I always felt like I was in control,
like I was, like, master manipulator.
- Mmhmm.
- Like, I could craft words in a way
to sell you a dream and tell you
I wasn't doing something that I was doing.
And just, like, a finesser, you know?
- Yeah.
- So that's just who I was, and at that point,
I could no longer, like, I couldn't fool myself.
I could fool everybody else.
But I couldn't fool myself.
- Mmhmm.
- So that was scary enough
for me to not wanna do it ever again.
- Yeah, it was like that
"looking in the mirror" moment.
- Yeah.
- Like, "All right, this is something
that I'm gonna have to change.
And I have decided."
- Right.
- I think you said in an interview
that it was Fentanyl?
- Yeah, it had to be, cuz
I was picking up the same pills.
Like, it wasn't, like, the most absurd
amount of pills ever, but it was, like, what
I had usually been getting,
and it would have me, like,
just on the couch
googly-eyed and shit. But, like,
it was something off about that
batch, you know? That
shit just put me down like "bam,"
so I knew there was something in it.
- So that has been in the
news a lot recently. Fentanyl use.
- Yeah, there's a girl from my third
grade class overdosed and died last night.
- No way.
- There was a girl I used to have a crush
on in my third grade class.
- Oh, no.
- Yeah.
Me and some of my friends,
we had dinner with her, like, back in
February. It was around,
like, the All-Star weekend.
- You just saw her.
- Yeah.
And yeah, she died last night.
- So when you see news,
not just about someone,
you know, specifically just news about,
like, how deadly Fentanyl is
and how it's affecting people,
is that a moment that is sad for you?
Is it triggering for you?
What is it like when you hear
about Fentanyl in the news
cuz it's happening so much?
- Yeah, it's just depressing, you know?
- Yeah.
- It doesn't really, like, trigger me
or anything, but it's like, it's just like,
it's depressing seeing, like, how people think
that these substances
can in a way, like, cure their problems
or, like, make these things go away.
It was like, you know, I realized
like every time I got high, it was like
my problems went away
for, like, a little bit.
But as soon as I woke up the next morning
or as soon as I came down, it was right outside the door
waiting for me like, "Come on."
- Yeah.
- Like, "You gonna have to deal with me at some point."
- So it's just sad that people think, like,
that's a way out or an escape
when it's really, like, you just delaying,
you know, what you're gonna
have to face at some point.
So I was listening to your second album,
"Delusions of Clarity,"
and there was—
- Third, technically.
- Third, technically. My bad.
And there was a lyric in there—
I wrote it down, let me
make sure I say it right—
where you talk about depression
controlling your mind.
- Yeah.
- I think that was in the intro song.
- Uh-huh.
- Were you saying that in a hyperbolic
way writing the lyric,
or is depression something that you do
genuinely struggle with?
- Um, yeah, it's something
that I struggle with for sure.
- Yeah.
- You know, it doesn't control my mind like
it used to, but it can kinda, you know,
dictate my days for a little bit.
Like, it won't be like a stretch of weeks
or months at a time.
But it could be, like, a day where I'm
just kinda like, man,
you know? People may be like, "Yo,
like, what's up? You good?" Cuz
usually I'll be, like, roasting people
or, like, you know, just being a goofball.
But then it's like some days, I just be like,
you could just tell I'm not really with it,
you know? I'll do what I have to do,
but I'm not really like,
you know, in my most bubbly
for my personality.
- Mmhmm.
- And so it, it does, it does still show up.
And, uh, it's like the other part of that
lyric is like, "Depression control my mind.
You wouldn't even know
cuz I'm grinning."
- Yeah.
- It's like, you know, like I said,
I can always manipulate and also, like,
laugh it off and put the smile on
and tell a joke and like,
you know, be in that for the moment.
But then it's like,
you know, when I'm by myself,
it's just, like, I'm back in that hole a little bit.
- Yeah.
So when I think about you, right, and
everything that you have gone through,
and then I think about a place like Vegas—
- Right. It sound crazy on paper.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- How—I mean, what
went through your mind, right?
Like, "I'm going to be in Vegas."
Like, is that something you're like,
"All right, this could not be great"?
Like, are those thoughts
that you have in your head sometimes?
- I mean, that's just where I think
God is just hilarious
sometimes. It's like, "Yeah, you 'bout to go
to where people get down at."
- Mmhmm
- "Like, you done got down there
a couple times, too."
But it's like, you know, you can go there,
and it's like if you're really walking in
the way that you supposed to be walking
or you say that you're walking,
you know, you can go there
and kinda, like, flip the script.
You know, you can go there and be—you
can have a good time,
have a good time more than
anybody else—and be sober.
You know? There's
no limit to the fun that you can have,
and you can just go about different
things. Like, I've developed
a new relationship
with, like, nature since I've been out here.
- Nice.
- So it's just, it's just things like that.
You can go about your business
differently, even though everybody around
you may be going about it their way.
- Mmhmm.
- You know, you don't have to do what they do.
- Yeah. Are there things
that you avoid doing here?
- I wouldn't necessarily avoid.
I just, you know,
I just create boundaries,
I guess? Like, I'm just like,
ain't no reason for me to go to the club.
Like, I don't even enjoy the club.
- Especially in Vegas. It's crazy.
- If I'm going to the club,
I'm trying to please somebody else.
- Yeah.
- Or I'm trying to be seen in front of other people.
And it's like half the time I get there,
I could fall asleep, standing up in there.
So it's like, I don't need to do that.
I just don't need to do that.
So it's like, I mean, clubs are the
only place where
I'm like, "Yeah, I'm not going." Like, it just
doesn't, you know, make sense for me to be there.
Like, it's just not how I'm moving.
So I'll just say that.
- As someone who has been so open—
and I feel like any football fan,
I mean, really any people fan, right?
Like, just might know your story. It's
something you discuss a lot.
Has that affected, like, romantic relationships
in your experience? Like, just
everyone knows so much about you already?
Is there like a hesitancy
sometimes for people?
- I feel like it may, like, have people
like, "Whoa." Like, this
may be a little scary for them.
But I feel like that may be, like
me, another way of me creating a boundary.
Like, if you not getting real
like this or, like, you know,
trying to be this open and vulnerable,
like, we ain't gonna be together.
Like, I'm not finna be with somebody
that's out living how I used to live,
you know? Cuz that could be a magnet to
attract me back to how I used to live, to my past.
So it's just, you know,
it just, it's a whole different standard
as far as dating now.
It's just a lot has it go into it
cuz it used to be, like, I would date
anybody that just wanted me or—
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm saying? For, like,
that appreciation, that affection—
- Oh, to be a guy. [Laughing]
- You know? And it's just like, you know
you deserve, you deserve better than that.
- Yeah. No, absolutely.
So talk to me about now.
What do you feel you deserve?
Not just in relationships
but, like, in life? Cuz you seem to have
this very strong sense of self, right?
And what's right, what's wrong
and what you need, what you want,
what you don't want, what you don't need.
What does that look like for you?
- You know, for me at this point,
it's just working towards, like, freedom,
you know? Just freedom from what
other people think, freedom from,
you know, my old thinking patterns,
because some of them still like
to pop their way up.
You know, just peace and serenity,
you know? I don't need, I don't
need too much.
I don't need, you know, the money
and all the extra stuff.
You know, I just, meaningful connections
and relationships with people.
- Mmhmm.
- Like whereas
before, you know, I would just sabotage
so many, and it's like I didn't feel like I deserved them.
And now it's like, nah, I feel like I'm
trying to develop myself in a way
where I can be loyal to somebody now.
I can be, you know, there
where somebody can lean on me.
It's not just about what I can get
from this, you know? So it's just
little things like that,
just peace and serenity
and just connection with other people.
Like, it's just those little things.
- Yeah.
What stage of your life
would you say you're in right now
if you had to title this
stage of your life?
- I don't know.
Transition.
- OK, why transition?
- I would say transitioning into a space
where, you know, I'm
not feeling the need to hide as much. Like,
I wanna isolate, like, in my own time.
But it's, like, stepping forward
into the light where people would,
you know, see me at all times.
And it's just, like,
you know, this whole Darren Waller thing, like,
you know, embracing it
because it's not about me.
Cuz like, I mean, sometimes
I'm just like, man, this social media shit. Like, man,
I'll delete my Instagram right now.
But it's, like—
- Yeah.
- it's bigger than me.
Like, it's affecting more people.
It's not necessarily about me.
It's about the impact
that it has on others.
- Mmhmm.
- So just trying to transition into that
and embracing that and knowing
that, you know, I may not always enjoy
everything that comes with it.
I may wanna be left alone.
But, you know, me wanting to isolate
keeps me from putting that message out
there orr people being able
to interact with me and,
you know, feel my energy and be able to
take that and continue to pass it on.
So it's just transitioning to that mode
where it's, like, all right, I'm embracing
everything that comes with this life.
- Yeah. So transitioning into that.
But transitioning out of what?
- Shame.
Just playing small. Settling.
Yeah. Not using my voice, not—being quiet
about things that I wanna speak on.
So it's just like, you know,
stepping into that role where it's, like,
having those conversations
and saying those things
that may be uncomfortable
for some people to hear.
But it's like, you know,
this is the life I'm living.
I'm not living it
to see how you would react.
- Mmhmm.
So are you, would you say you are at peace
right now with who you are?
- I would say with who I am, yeah.
Just cuz I know
that I'm giving things, like, an honest try.
You know, I'm trying to live this life
the best way that I can in an authentic way,
you know? There are still some hiccups.
I'm not, I'm far from perfect. To anybody listening,
I'm not perfect.
They may try to paint that picture
sometimes, but that's just not it,
you know, so. But I'm at peace
with who I am cuz of just the effort
that put in to try to, you know, be
that person that I think I can become.
- But then are you at peace in general?
Cuz you were hesitating
until I added the "with yourself" part.
- Yeah. I mean—
- Yeah.
- Like I was saying, this last week has been kinda, like, whew.
Like, just I don't feel like I've been
necessarily at peace this last week.
I feel like I'm just kinda getting
pulled in a million different directions.
- Yeah.
- But, you know, last night was a great night
for me to kinda realize, like,
you know, this stuff is cool
and it's important, but, like, it's
not the ultimate priority.
- Mmhmm.
- So last night was a chance for me to just…
[exhaling]
Like, went to a meeting, went to my
therapist, you know what I'm saying?
And it was just like a chance
for me to just be like, all right,
like, let all this shit go for a minute and just—
- Yeah.
- Chill out.
- Yes. Go, therapy!
I feel like we talk about
therapy on this show—
- Oh, yeah, ain't nothing wrong with—
- Like, all the time.
- Ain't nothing wrong with getting you a therapist.
- Everyone should try therapy, yeah.
- Get you a therapist.
- Yeah.
- Treat yourself.
- What is the, like,
your main takeaway from therapy so far?
What do you think that has helped you
with the most in terms
of, like, your personality,
what you have to work on?
- I think, like, reframing things.
- Mmhmm.
- You know, because I can just be so quick to be, like,
beat myself up still,
you know, for things. And
therapy has allowed me to have a chance
to reframe certain things
and be like, well, no, no, I can
see it in a different way.
The first way my mind presents it to me
doesn't always have to be the way
that I have to go with. Like—
- Yeah,
- If I wanna speak up and say
anything about, you know,
something at work isn't going
the way I want it to. It's like, if I wanna
go speak on it, it's not like, "Oh, man,
it's my ego .I think I'm the biggest
guy in the world so I can say whatever I want."
It's, like, no, this is something I feel like is
really affecting me, and in a team environment,
we communicate honestly.
We're like brothers.
It's a brotherhood.
And we're in this together.
- Mmhmm.
- So these things need to be put out there
instead of avoid it or let it fester
inside me or something,
you know?
- Yeah.
- So it's just things like that,
I can reframe these things in my mind.
I'm not always in the wrong, or I'm not always
thinking I have a big head or
anything like that. It's just like—
- Yeah.
- All right, man,
like, settle down, and let's
look at it from an objective perspective.
- Mmhmm. And you can just, like,
let it out in there, right?
Like, there's like a release
that comes with going to therapy.
I saw you say, John Harbaugh,
you were in a meeting room,
and he said, "OK, if you don't love
football, you should leave."
- Right.
- And at that time, you wanted to give up,
and you wanted to leave?
- Yes.
- So at that time, you did not.
- Correct.
- Now, if someone said, "If you don't love
football, leave," would you leave?
Do you love football again now?
- Yeah, I love football.
You know, I feel like I'm committed,
even though, you know, some days
I may not always feel like it.
Some days I may kinda
be like, man. Like, God, like,
you got me here, but you know, I'm here.
But so it's like, you know,
I feel like I love it
and I'm more committed to it.
Like, no matter the feelings,
no matter my energy level,
like, I'mma show up and do it
because, like, this team is bigger than me.
This sport is bigger than me.
And people are—like I said,
I try to take that perspective everywhere
I go. Like, it's just bigger than me.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah.
- Yeah. Has refocusing into
that, like, kind of saved you in some ways,
having that for you?
- Yeah. Yeah. It is.
It's just, like, you know,
cuz I—me naturally as a person,
I want things to just be comfortable and,
you know, the path of least resistance.
And it's, like, you know, let's
just kinda frolic through here,
and, you know, this will be fun.
- Walk in the park, yeah.
- But it's, like, football
is challenging day in and day out.
You know, you got to earn that shit
every day at practice. You know, you're
competing against guys, and, you know,
they're evaluating you every day.
So you gotta show up and be committed
to just growing every single day.
- Mmhmm.
- Like, this is such a long season.
If you just commit to,
you know, I'm improving. As long as
this thing is going, I'm improving.
And it just translates over to life.
You kinda feel good about yourself
cuz, like, I did
everything I could today. Like,
"Good job, me."
- Yeah.
- Let's keep going.
Let's do this in everything in life.
- Mmhmm.
- Yeah, it saves me.
- Yeah, I love that. Football saved you.
Speaking of, I mean, someone you have just
been an amazing peer to is Maxx Crosby.
Talk to me about that relationship
and also just what it feels like to know,
like, your presence had such a direct
and immediate impact on one other person.
- Maxx is incredible, man.
Maxx is, you know, real cool dude,
real smooth cat,
you know, but he's, like, now
he's so dialed in on just
taking care of himself
and, you know, his craft and just
how he wants to live and, you know,
who he wants to become.
And, you know, it's incredible
to see because we've
been through a similar path.
It's just, like, we thought living the way
that we do now would be, like, lame
and boring and, like, "Why would we ever do
that? That sounds trash. Like, sober?"
- [Laughing]
- Like, nah.
And so it's just, like, to see him shining and just, like,
loving every single second of it
and just being that energy, where it's like,
I mean, this man sets the stadium on fire,
just, like, with his, just being himself.
So it's—
- Mmhmm.
- I mean, it's incredible to see.
And he took, like, he may have taken things
from my experience,
and I may have impacted him,
but he made the choice to,
you know, continue to walk in it
every single day and still does.
And he doesn't need
anybody to motivate him
or tell him, "You gotta do this, you gotta do that."
He wants to do it, and he's
convicted to do it.
And that's what I admire
the most.
- Oh, I love that.
And he has a verse.
- Yeah.
- On your album.
- It's the last song, right?
- Yes. Yeah.
- Maxx is such a cool name.
Like, with two X's. It sounds like a rapper.
- Yeah, Maxx is too cool.
- Yeah [laughing].
- Maxx is too cool.
- Why did you call it
"Delusions of Clarity"?
Like, what does that mean?
- I mean, the name
came to me like a couple years ago.
You know, ideas, just, I don't even know
where they be comin' from.
I swear it's God. Like, he just
be dropping gems.
And I was just, like,
"Delusions of Clarity"
just came to me, and I was like,
let me write that down. And I just kept it.
And I kinda started
making, like, a "Delusions of Clarity" album,
like, in 2019.
This is, like, when I first started making,
first started making music, 2018.
- Mmhmm.
- And some of the songs in there,
well, they were dope to me.
But I was like, you know,
like, I can go harder than this.
And I was just like, man,
let me just, like, scrap that.
This was before I even made "Wall Street,"
I came up with that name.
- OK.
- And so I just kinda, it just kinda lingered,
and I was just like, wow.
Like, I was developing these songs,
and I was just like,
now this still applies because it's, like,
my thinking was so clouded up and just,
you know, dark and confused in the past.
But it's like it took that experience
to get to a place of clarity.
- Yeah.
- And, you know,
knowing what my purpose is and knowing
why I'm here and, you know, and walking
in that with, you know, with convictions.
So I feel like that title definitely fits.
- Yeah, absolutely.
OK, I wanna close out with two things.
Have you ever played peak and pit?
Do you know what that is?
The peak and the pit?
- I don't know.
- So we're gonna talk
about this past year, OK?
And you're gonna tell me your peak,
which is the highest point that you had
this year, where you were happiest, right?
Then you're gonna tell me your pit, which was
the lowest time that you had this year.
- [Waller sighing]
- Do you wanna start
with your peak or your pit?
- I mean, I think my—
I don't know, what's my pit?
I think one of my—my pit might have been...
I had a teammate in Baltimore
that he was the only dude I would hang out with,
and, you know, we were like,
we were on the same wave.
Like, we were just doing the same shit.
And he died, like, of like
from using what
we were using back in the day.
And so that was rough because it was, like,
it really started to hit home, you know?
And that was after, you know, one of my best
friends lost his mother to alcoholism.
And so it was just, like, things just started
to hit close to home, you know?
And I was just kinda
thinking to myself, like,
"Am I really doing, like, the work that I say
that I'm doing?" Cuz, you know,
these people that I don't even know hear it,
and it's like, OK, they get it. But it's, like,
there's people closest to me that are dying,
that are still struggling,
that are still doing the same thing.
Like, some of my friends from back home.
that I kicked it with a lot still on the same shit.
And it's like, am I really making
that kind of impact,
or is this all just, like, or
am I really, like, a fraud kinda thing?
And so I feel like that was,
you know, a time where I was just,
you know, in my head a lot.
And it was, you know, tough to shake out of
cuz it's like,
you know, you wanna save people.
But it's like, you know,
people gotta be ready to help themselves,
and then you can help them.
- So you're saying it
it just felt, like, maybe
all the things that you were doing
weren't adding up to the change
you wanted to see because people you knew
personally—
- Yeah.
- Were still falling
into those same traps and substances
and things like that?
- Yeah. It was just like, yeah, all this stuff
you're doing is cute and everything,
but it's still not enough cuz you ain't even
making a change to people that's close to you.
It's just, like, that's the narrative
that's going on in my head.
So dealing with that was, like,
it was a little rough.
- But you do know you are impacting
so many people, right?
- Yeah.
- Or are you still today, you're
kinda like, "Eh, I don't know"?
- I'm still, like, ducking
that voice a little bit,
but it's like I can see it now,
and I try to verbalize it.
Like, I realized speaking things out loud
has more of an impact.
Cuz you can think, like, "OK,
I'm thinking a positive thought right now."
But it's like if you say it out loud,
like, now I'm really making an impact.
Like, I'm really doing something
that's changing the world, and the world
is gonna be a better place because I was here,
because of the way that I'm walking.
- Mmhmm.
- And you say it out loud, and it's like, it
just has a different effect.
- Totally.
- You know?
- Yeah.
- So that's, I had to
learn how to do that.
- And is there, and correct me if I'm wrong,
but is there, like, an element of
almost, like, guilt
when someone that you know is in a place
that you once were but you no longer are in?
- Yeah. It's like—yeah. Cuz, you
know, it's like I have the—
you know, I've been through it.
You know, I kinda have an idea
of what it takes to, you know,
see things on the other side.
But it's like, and then I think that
my ego thinks that
that directly applies to me going
and taking that person and walking them
through everything and making them—
but it's like, nah, they have to have
their own experience.
- Mmhmm.
- So it's like I have to view that voice
as like, nah, that's irrational.
I'm not attaching myself to that.
And I'm not gonna allow that to be
what's going on in my head.
- Mmhmm.
- So it's just, it's
a battle, day in, at all times.
- Well, I mean, you have affected
so many people, but you know,
you can always think, "I know
I directly affected Maxx."
So, you know, there is, like, a huge impact
that you are having on
so many players,
people, whoever, just human beings, so.
- Right.
- Just keep that with you. Your peak?
- Hmm. My peak. I would say
it was probably, like, a month ago.
My foundation, we started giving grants
to people to go to treatment
at this place called Landmark Recovery.
It's, like, North Vegas,
not too far from here.
- Mmhmm.
- And, you know,
they give you, like, the grant applications
of, you know, people like age 18 to 26
that don't really have the money to pay
for it themselves
and, or the insurance or anything.
And so it's like, I approved the grants.
I see the names on there.
And, you know, it's Heather, Greg and Desmond.
And you see the names, like, OK, like, this,
I feel like they could benefit from this,
from reading, like, their profile
and their story and everything.
And they go through the program,
but then it's like, I go to the place,
and I actually got to meet them.
- Oh, great.
- And they, like, were
just, like, oozing with gratitude.
- Yeah.
- And just hearing their stories. Like,
you know, Heather was
in and out of prison and has a child
and is, like, you know,
trying to turn her life around.
And she was like, "This experience is
what is allowing me to do that."
- Yeah.
- And there was this dude Desmond
who was, he said he was just, like, walking out
in the desert, was just like,
said he was just over this shit. And was like,
you know, thought he was gonna die out there
cuz he was walking around with, like, no water,
not eating nothing.
- Mmhmm.
- And he was like, "This being here
and this program
has changed me and, like, you know,
I have a new outlook on life, new hope."
And it's just like being around them
and just talking to them,
it was crazy. And it was like,
you know, the foundation,
they try to, like, get the word out to people,
so there was, like, cameras
and news people there.
- Yeah.
- And so I thought it was just gonna be,
like, a five-minute thing.
I kinda, like, shake their hand
and make it look cute.
But it was like, we were sitting there talking for, like,
45 minutes, and the news people were just like—
- That's great.
- Like, what is—and it was just
awesome to connect with them.
- Yeah.
- And realize, like, those moments
where it's like, I can be in my head
and be like, "Am I really impacting people?"
But they were there like, "Bro, thank you."
- Living. Breathing.
- Like, "thank you." And I was just like,
wow, this is a bit crazier
than anything on a football field
or anything like that.
- Oh, I love that. Well, you were a pleasure.
You are easily one of my favorite people
that I have interviewed.
And not because I think you're perfect,
but because, like, I know you're not.
Because you tell us,
because you talk about everything
that you've been through
and where you're going.
So I deeply appreciate the time.
But you gotta end with your favorite
quote since you're, like, quote master.
And I love quotes. Like, I have quotes
in this show all the time.
So tell me your favorite.
- It's tough, man.
The one I go with is Winston Churchill.
Shoutout to Winston Churchill.
- Shoutout to Winston.
- That guy's tatted on my ankle,
- Shoutout Winston Churchill.
- For real.
- I've never heard anyone say that.
- [Laughing]
Yeah, nah, but, he said, "Success is moving from failure
to failure without losing enthusiasm."
- Mmm. Shoutout to Winston.
- That shit hit different.
- Yeah. What do you take from that?
- For me, it's, like, success
isn't always in the results.
But more so, like, just how I show up
every day. Like, my process,
you know? The impact that I leave
is not about, you know,
anything that's in a bank account—
- Yeah.
- Or in the driveway or anything like that.
It's just, you know, I can fail
and fall on my face in a thousand times,
but I could still live a life
that is impactful and has meaning,
you know? It doesn't have to be perfect.
It doesn't have to fit an image or be like,
you know, "Everything's great over here."
Like, shit can suck.
- Yeah.
- But I can still, you know, consider myself successful
because I'm putting forth the effort
and trying to live life
with the right attitude
and just the right perspective.
- Yes. And success is what you make it.